hello everyone I'm midi I'm a senior
product manager at atlassian and today I
will be walking you through the process
of crafting a winning product strategy a
blueprint for success for new product
managers
as a view of introduction I started my
career at Cummins in the manufacturing
industry as a strategy and planning
business analyst I then moved to Splunk
and I started that as a cloud business
process analyst and recently I've been
leaving Splunk was in the platform
product management team
and more recently I've been working at
atlassian as their senior product
manager for Confluence Cloud
specifically focused on Confluence
permissions
let's dive in today I will be talking
you through three topics the first one
being product Discovery tactics the
second where we will spend our most time
today is on Crafting the strategy which
also includes activity ideas and lastly
sharing and gaining alignment
but small disclaimer here none of what I
represent here in this talk today is a
representation of the companies that I
had previously worked at or will be
working at these are purely just my
opinions and things that I have learned
through my experience
all right
so think through when you're a new
product manager you might either be new
to the product management role or new to
the product feature a team new to the
organization company or simply just
completely new to The Domain
it is very hard to visualize when you
don't know what the current is you
simply cannot visualize what you don't
know and so it is critical to dive very
quickly into the product to understand
the current state of things so that you
can then map out what the future looks
like and how to get there
and I have found that three pillars of
the way to structure this has really
helped me dive very quickly into the
product and start to understand how it
works today
the first among them is stakeholder
interviews so when you think about
the company or the immediate people that
you work with think about who might be
people who might know something about
the product or feature that you're
responsible for
um make a list of at least three people
this one of them could just be the
manager who hired you or the person who
brought you into this team or onto this
product
um and to other people make that list
which is a very short list to start with
and think through a template of
questions that you might want to ask
them things like uh what are your
priorities currently and what are your
priorities in the next six months how do
you see that overlapping with this thing
that I am responsible for do you see our
priorities aligning what um have you
used this thing that I'm responsible for
and what are your opinions on it probing
questions like these really start to
help you identify where there is overlap
between your area of work and something
else that someone might be responsible
for
finally you would want to schedule and
run these interviews so that you can
take notes plenty of documentation
during the interview and one key Step
Beyond conducting the interviews is to
synthesize and form summarized notes
that you can refer to later on
from all of these interviews
the next Builder that I think is
critical for all product managers to do
is user research
um the farthest away that a product
manager is from their customer the users
that they are solving a problem for the
less likely it is that they are solving
the right problem so it is extremely
important for product managers to get in
touch with the users to learn how the
users feel about their area that they're
responsible for and one way to go about
doing that or to start with that is by
reviewing any existing research that was
conducted in the past this could have
been research that a different product
manager who was in your role before
might have done maybe a different
function like the user research team may
have done some research there may be
existing things that you already know
about your users that you would want to
dig up and uncover and go through
and the whole point of this is to start
to form an opinion so when you look at
it when you're new to as a product
manager you have you have this blank
canvas ahead of you what you need to
start to do is to form your opinions and
start to draw on that canvas
so that
um you could then have a baseline for
things that you would want to change and
that goes into the second bullet of
synthesized specific things that you
wish to learn because the canvas that
you're working with might be very large
the list of things that you don't know
will be very large you need to take the
time to narrow it down to exact things
that you want to learn from your users
and then conduct the user interviews and
in this conducting the user interviews
you might think about how do you recruit
them like the communications you send
out before recruiting them how do you
pre-select and narrow down the kind of
users that you do want to interview
you'd also want to think through things
like uh rewards do you want to
monetarily
Revolt your interviewees for that time
and what will you do Post interview the
communications that you'll send out to
them after that interview is done
so doing this user research will really
help you get in touch with the customers
and the users that you're trying to
solve a problem for
very critical for any product manager to
do
um sometimes there might not be fast
research for you to reference
um this third pillar can help with that
but even outside of that competitive
analysis is really critical for you to
know exactly what is out there how are
other tools solving this problem do my
customers have other ways of solving
this already do they like those ways do
they have workarounds but those are very
hard to do all of these questions can be
answered by doing a competitive analysis
by taking a look at all the other tools
that are solving this problem in the
market today and how they're doing it
one of the ways that I have found for
this competitive analysis that's been
successful is a secret shopping exercise
just as the name suggests the secret
shopper exercise stays like imagine you
are the product manager for the checkout
process in an e-commerce website
what a secret shopper exercise would be
is you would assume the role of the user
who would use your product so in this
case you're the person who's trying to
buy something from that e-commerce
website and then you go through that
checkout process yourself and throughout
that time you would be writing down uh
the things that you like things that you
don't like ideas that you have with the
whole point being that you are now
almost being a Critic to your own
product and documenting that as you go
and then repeat the same thing in those
competitor tools using Frameworks like
what strength weakness opportunities
threats or something as simple as that
where you're able to document your
competitive analysis will really help
you provide some structure and a
framework to this analysis
I do really believe that these three
pillars can help structure your product
Discovery and some tips on this
for the stakeholder interviews
ask each person that you talk to for the
contact of one other person for you to
talk to this way you're expanding your
network and growing that list that you
started with
for user research
um maybe try doing something fun like a
one minute rapid fire round where to ask
your user to rate X number of features
and that could be
um very enlightening for you to know do
your users even recognize these features
do they like it do they not like it you
could make this numerical ask them to
rate it on a scale of 10.
and the tip on competitive analysis is
you could make this a team activity it
doesn't have to be something that you do
by yourself it could be a team activity
you could assign one
product or one competitive tool to each
group or each person who is helping you
out and each of them does the same
exercise follows the same steps in those
tools and you then have this the all the
documentation that's created for all of
these different tools
one thing I would say is there is no
substitute for you going into those
competitor to yourself and doing that
sort of analysis yourself so be sure to
make the time for that at some point it
doesn't have to be right now when
everything is new to you
so yes
um these are the product Discovery tools
how can you as a new product manager
quickly start to learn about your
product and its current state
going into the next topic which is
crafting the strategy
there are three key components of a
strategy document the first one being
what is the problem the second is who
are we solving for and third is how will
we be solving it
um these three components are basically
the main things that someone will look
for when you share a strategy document
with them and not having any of these
pieces will really make will leave a lot
of questions unanswered for the reader
or whoever is consuming your strategy
document
for this first one on what is the
problem two main pieces that that you
would want your strategy to to answer
the first of them is the problem
statement what exactly is the problem
that we are trying to solve for written
out in an easy to consume manner for
anyone to be able to understand it
and the second one is data proving why
this is worth solving right now and that
data could be in the form of competitive
insights that you gained by in this in
the previous exercise of competitive
analysis it could also be a reviewing
feature requests and different companies
have different Avenues of collecting
future requests some companies have a
support team so create support tickets
and uh you would see the number of
support tickets on a certain topic and
know that it's important for the
customers some companies also do a
public ticketing system where customers
can create those tickets themselves the
other customers can then vote on it and
so the highly voted tickets would be the
ones that you would know are worth
solving right now
but the main
um
the main aim of this section on what is
the problem is to set uh some contacts
for your reader on what is the rest of
the strategy document going to talk
about it's about this problem that
you're trying to solve
on that
um here's a fun activity that you could
run to get to answering what is the
problem and it could be this well-known
commonly known exercise called The Rose
Thorn Bud exercise that's also called I
like I wish I wonder activity or the
start stop continue activity
there are templates out there that you
could reuse I just shown some templates
from mural and figma basically a way for
you to start to think about what are the
things that are going well what are the
things that should absolutely change and
what are the other things that maybe are
ideas or opportunities but
um really just words right now that can
grow into more later on
doing this Rose stone part exercise
either by yourself while you're doing
the secret sharpen exercise in your
product or with your team where you just
have a group of people who come together
and think through all the things that
you know all of these prompts would
really help so at the end of this
activity what you can expect is a bunch
of sticky notes whether you're doing it
in a digital tool or physically on the
Whiteboard you would have a bunch of
sticky notes which will then give you an
understanding of very quickly what are
the things that are going well right now
what are the things that need to change
again what are the ideas that we have
um so yeah that's a fun activity for
what is the problem
and then once you have written out with
the what is the problem section the
second thing to highlight in the
strategy document is who are we solving
for well um this problem that exists who
is it a problem for and there are two
main things to include in that section
the first one being in the form of user
personas highlighting
um exactly who we are going to solve for
an example of this might be you might
think of an admin Persona and then you
might think of an end user persona
uh I've written here that user personas
with segmentation is a good idea you
would want to think through other
different ways to segment my target
audience and it could be small business
versus Enterprise it could be paid user
versus the user who's on a free trial
um it could be geographically someone
who is accessing something from Amer
versus APAC region so a way to classify
so that you're then able to really
critically look at the user personas the
breadth of user personas and exactly who
you want to Target
um The Who I'll be solving for Section
also usually has the top user pain
points that you're trying to solve for
so the pain points would be accompanied
by customer codes to drive home the
point on this is really a problem and
here's what the customers are saying
about this right now and a lot of the
times those customer codes or the top
user 10 points could be accompanied by a
y and this would be in terms of a job to
be done that the customer was trying to
do so I was trying to do something but
here's the problem and it's really
something that I think needs to change
right now and therefore it's a top user
pain point this is what you're trying to
drive with this section
um for these two
um here's a fun activity that could be
worth doing with the team or by yourself
and again there are templates on pigma
and mural that can be used in creating
these user personas
one way to go about it is to think about
end to end every single different user
type that your process or your system
might touch and why that's um
what is the thing that attracts them or
keeps them irrelevant to that process or
system and so
um you would come up with this profile
of in that previous example of an admin
an admins main job to be done is X Y and
Z but they are
um you know they're an introvert seen in
the stigma
template that we have here since they're
an introvert they don't communicate
often enough and we need an easier
Reaper than to
create a ticket for example and so that
is their pain point
um using these to really drive home who
is the user Persona that we're trying to
solve for will allow us to come up with
that that second part of the strategy
document on what is that target audience
that we're solving this problem for
lastly is how will we be solving it and
for how will we be solving it it could
be as
um as Broad and deep as you want it to
be and usually this is where most
readers or people who are consuming your
strategy document are going to spend
their time on number one and number two
is really just setting the stage the
context and who it really impacts but
number three is where we're really going
and driving the point home on what the
future is
and there are four key things here as
listed which is division with a time
frame time frame here could include
vision for fiscal year 23 to 25 or net
the two-year Vision so basic usually
this vision is accompanied by a time
frame that the vision is applicable for
the second aspect on in this section is
guiding principles
the third one is strategies and roadmap
on how we will get there and the last
one is Success metrics and okrs I will
be touching on all four of these in the
coming slides so just this is just a
brief list on the things that are
included in this section
before we go into that list there are
some key terms to refresh or review and
to understand better
when we say Vision a vision usually
communicates what we will be achieving
in the future and it's used to align and
inspire a group of people about a shared
goal
strategies are used to communicate how
people achieve that vision
okrs or objectives and key results are
measurable goals that achieve that
Vision so how are we going to achieve
that Vision that we can track using
these okrs these are Stepping Stones
towards implementing our strategies
and lastly guiding principles guiding
principles are an agreed upon set of
models that will guide our decision
making I'll touch on all of these in the
coming slides but here's what the
interaction between them looks like
a vision describes an ideal future that
is achieved by the strategies
the strategies are converted into
actionable objectives and those
objectives are influenced by The Guiding
principles and the achievement of those
objectives is measured using the key
results
um specifically this Vision piece of a
strategy document is very important and
usually a vision is written in this
manner which is like I see a world where
XYZ happens and so when you think of
this framing this really helps in
creating a vision statement
and here I just have some examples that
I picked up from various thoughts this
these are just santos there's nothing
here to say that these are the exact
relation statements of these companies
but if mission statements for famous
companies were public
maybe this is what they might look like
for Nike to bring inspiration and
Innovation to every athlete in the world
Apple a computer in the hands of
Everyday People
Disney make people happy
investors help themselves
so what you will see here is these
vision statements are inspiring and
Visionary they help to see the future of
exactly what that future looks like
two tips here
doing just a quick 15-minute brainstorm
session with a five plus group of people
will get you some rough ideas for vision
statements and a way to do this would be
to just give a prompt for example
Confluence permissions
um and tell them hey write one statement
on what do you think Confluence
permissions in the ideal world would
look like and so you have a bunch of
different statements all rough and need
to be polished and so that's where the
second tip comes in use tools that we
have like Ai and you start GPT to refine
their vision statement and make your
work easier in coming up with a
sustained yet inspiring way to capture
your vision of where you want your
product to go
the next thing is the strategies and
roadmap so strategy is really a
statement on we will achieve this Vision
by
uh strategy is usually not just one
single statement it's a bunch of things
that we will do so it's the how we will
get the vision
we had done the rose Bond part exercise
previously so my suggestion here is to
take that and continue group those uh
previous sticky notes that we got into
themes and then use the data that you've
gathered from your first round of
product deep dies in order to inform the
priority between these themes lastly you
assign timelines based on the overall
company priorities and Engineering
feasibility to come up with what now
looks like a roadmap so you would have
these ideas and then you'll have some
time that is associated with completion
of each idea and then you'll also have
priority and that together
is as easy as having your strategies and
roadmap finished
so if you take a look at the how we'll
be solving it the one thing I didn't
touch on is the success metrics and
objectives and key results these are as
simple as they sound is to a measurable
way to really track for
um the success of the project or product
feature that you're building exactly how
will you know that you've been
successful in releasing and
solving a customer need
so in that this is the summary of the
strategy document three key components
one the inspection should be around what
is the problem the next one around who
are we solving for and the last one is
how we will be solving it so all of this
together encompasses the strategy
document
the last
topic here was around sharing and
gaining alignment not only do you write
up your product strategy it's also
important for you to then share it out
broadcast it and then gain alignment on
that strategy dog
um
there are I would say and there's an
iterative process with sharing and
gaining alignment
the first one is really share it with
more people you could consider sharing
it broadly so you would share it across
your entire team or you could take it
vertically you can share it higher up to
leadership you can share it to other
teams that you work with
cross-functionally across to engineering
and design and product marketing what
you really want to do here is to try and
get more people to take a look at the
strategy document and
um
start to evaluate it start to align with
your idea of the future and that's where
the second aspect comes in which is
seeking feedback
it's important to align on the
priorities with the partner teams they
another team takes a look at your
strategy document and realizes you have
prioritized A over B and they have an
influence over p and they cannot do it
at that time that you have indicated in
your roadmap now is the time to really
seek that feedback and align on those
priorities and seek the help that you
need to get the priorities right
um where one day pure is when you do get
feedback it's it's great if you can get
that clarified whether it is a
suggestion whether it's a must do or an
opinion usually when you get feedback uh
from this from leadership team it is
important to get this so that you know
exactly how you should be the in taking
that feedback
and the third one here is on updating
the strategy document this one I would
personally say is the hardest it's easy
to come up and write up a document and
it's the hardest to keep it up to date
um make changes based on the feedback
but also update it periodically to keep
that document relevant and alive
and then repeat further document with
more people will give you more feedback
updated again and then this is iterative
as you get more and more people using
and sharing your strategy document
and that's everything
that I wanted to cover today on Crafting
a winning product strategy the blueprint
for Success uh new product managers can
go about writing their strategy document
for their product
thank you so much for your time